Traduttore: Michele Gianella
Revisore: Federico MINELLE
Noi siamo all'alba
della civilizzazione digitale.
Ce ne siamo accorti, probabilmente,
perché la posta è diventata elettronica,
perché la musica e i film
sono diventati liquidi,
perché tutto ciò che una volta
pesava sui nostri scaffali,
pensiamo alle enciclopedie,
è scomparso, sostituito da Wikipedia.
Bene, oggi c'è l'aspettativa,
a torto o ragione,
che un intero sistema
bancario e finanziario
entri nei nostri smartphone.
Lo aveva già predetto, peraltro,
un premio Nobel per l'economia
come Milton Friedman,
il quale nel '99 ha detto:
ciò che manca, e che sarà
sicuramente inventato a breve,
è una forma di contante digitale -
badate, non di moneta elettronica,
che è associata a degli individui,
ma di contante al portatore,
utilizzabile senza identificazione,
da tutti, su Internet.
Ecco, quella profezia vede oggi
la sua realizzazione in bitcoin,
che è assolutamente
in pole position in questa gara.
Perché?
Non tanto per il fatto
di essere evidentemente digitale:
anche i nostri euro e dollari, di fatto,
sono ormai da tempo digitali.
Quanto per essere decentralizzato:
non ha cioè, alle sue spalle,
un'organizzazione, un governo
che in qualche maniera ne coordinino,
facciano da supervisori
del suo funzionamento.
E questo, anche se un po' ci inquieta,
è in realtà una garanzia molto forte
sul fatto che Bitcoin
non potrà mai essere manipolato.
Si tratta di quella forma di innovazione
che gli anglosassoni chiamano
"permissionless innovation".
Cosa si intende per un'innovazione
che non chiede permesso?
È un'innovazione che non ha
meccanismi di sicurezza centralizzati,
che non ha controlli all'ingresso,
che non ha un sistema
di controllo editoriale dei contenuti.
Se vi sembra un piano
un po' troppo anarchico,
e vi state spaventando,
no, non fatelo.
È un'innovazione
che avete già visto all'opera,
e sa essere molto efficace,
ma anche molto gentile.
L'e-mail, ad esempio,
non è stato inventato
da un consorzio di uffici postali.
Internet non è stata inventata
da un consorzio di telecomunicazioni.
Per quale motivo un network
transazionale del valore
debba essere inventato
da un consorzio di banche -
beh, lasciatemi dire che il sottoscritto
lo trova alquanto implausibile.
Io ho scoperto Bitcoin nel 2014.
Di formazione sono un fisico,
e ho lavorato per oltre 20 anni
nel mondo delle banche di investimento
su finanza e derivati.
Bene, io non mi ero mai posto la domanda
su cosa fosse la moneta.
La prima volta in vita mia
che me la sono posta
fu quando ho scoperto Bitcoin.
Questo è il più bel regalo
che Bitcoin mi abbia finora fatto.
E allora proverei con voi,
giocosamente s'intende,
a fare tutta la storia
della moneta in tre minuti.
Proviamoci.
La prima forma di moneta
che vediamo affermarsi nella storia
è l'oro.
Perché l'oro?
Vi sembrerà strano, ma per due
caratteristiche fondamentali:
perché è scarso e perché luccica.
Sì, pare che ci piacciano veramente molto,
a noi esseri umani, le cose che luccicano.
L'oro è anche molto malleabile,
e apprezzarne la purezza
è relativamente facile.
Prendete un paiolo,
accendete un fuoco sotto,
fate fondere l'oro,
attendete che si raffreddi.
Se, dopo questo violentissimo
ciclo termodinamico, luccica ancora è oro;
qualsiasi altra cosa,
vi garantisco, smette di luccicare.
Se però, per ogni transazione commerciale
noi dovessimo accendere un paiolo -
insomma, è piuttosto faticoso.
Ecco che allora abbiamo chiesto
a Giulio - sì, Giulio Cesare:
senti, Giulio,
perché non metti la tua faccia
sulla moneta d'oro
in maniera da garantirne
il suo contenuto aureo?
La prima crisi inflazionaria della storia
è già sotto il successore
di Giulio Cesare, Cesare Augusto.
Anche la plebe si rende conto
che nel sesterzio non c'è l'oro
che dovrebbe esserci.
Ma se siete un mercante medioevale,
l'oro ha anche un altro problema:
pesa tantissimo,
ha una densità elevatissima,
e quindi è scomodo da portar dietro.
Nonché piuttosto pericoloso,
perché i briganti possono derubarvi.
E allora quasi contemporaneamente,
nella storia, gli orefici londinesi
e quelli che diventeranno
i banchieri italiani
hanno la stessa idea:
propongono ai mercanti
di lasciare l'oro presso i loro forzieri
e danno in cambio un certificato
che è prima nominativo,
ma poi diventa al portatore:
è una nota di banco con la quale,
presso il loro banco pegni,
è possibile redimere l'oro depositato.
Nasce la banconota,
moneta rappresentativa
di valore custodito altrove.
Entrambi, però,
non resistono alla tentazione
perché fanno un'osservazione fondamentale:
notano che ben pochi
redimono la banconota in oro,
e quindi hanno quella che potremmo
definire un'alzata di ingegno.
Se emettiamo più banconote
dell'oro che abbiamo nei nostri forzieri,
chi se ne accorge?
E la risposta sapete qual'è?
Nessuno!
Nasce quindi la moneta frazionaria.
Ci sono più banconote
dell'oro che c'è a garanzia.
Andiamo veloci nella storia: 1972,
pur in un regime di moneta frazionaria,
la redimibilità aurea delle monete,
o del dollaro statunitense
nel caso che stiamo analizzando,
resta un po' una palla al piede
della discrezionalità
di politica monetaria.
Ecco che allora Richard Nixon
decide che no, basta:
il dollaro statunitense
non è più convertibile in oro.
Da allora abbiamo Fiat money,
proprio nel senso di
"Fiat Lux et Lux Fuit":
moneta che ha valore solo convenzionale,
solo perché decidiamo che abbia valore
da contratto sociale.
E se qualcuno non è d'accordo con noi,
lo costringiamo attraverso una cosa
che si chiama "corso legale":
cioè l'irrifiutabilità del fiat money
nell'estinzione di un debito.
Lasciatemi dire che questa moneta
è una cattiva moneta,
anzi potremmo anche dire
una pessima moneta:
senza andare a guardare esempi
assolutamente macroscopici,
o deleteri, della storia della moneta,
anche il buon vecchio,
caro dollaro statunitense
non ha proprio
una performance impeccabile.
Pensate che dal 1913,
l'anno di fondazione
della Federal Reserve,
il dollaro statunitense ha perso
oltre il 96 per cento
del suo potere di acquisto:
è quindi una cattiva moneta,
tipico risultato
di una situazione di monopolio.
Friedrich von Hayek,
Premio Nobel per l'economia
e fondatore della scuola austriaca
del pensiero economico,
scrive un intero trattato
lamentando il fatto
che "noi possiamo considerare
il monopolio governativo della moneta
come indispensabile.
Noi che non accetteremmo
il monopolio di nulla, di nessun bene,
in un'economia di mercato,
accettiamo proprio il monopolio
di quel bene sintetico
che entra al 50 percento
di qualunque transazione commerciale,
cioè la moneta.
Come tutti i monopoli,
non solo ci ha dato un cattivo prodotto,
ma ci ha impedito di sperimentare
alla ricerca di prodotti migliori."
E allora, concluderà Hayek,
"semmai vorremo rivedere una buona moneta,
dobbiamo toglierla dalle mani degli Stati.
E siccome non possiamo farlo
con la violenza -
bontà sua, e io mi adeguo
volentieri a questo invito,
dovremo farlo con un astuto stratagemma,
qualcosa che non possano fermare".
Bitcoin è esattamente
questo astuto stratagemma.
Ma proviamo ad approfondire
più intrinsecamente che cosa è la moneta.
La moneta è fondamentalmente
uno strumento di relazione sociale.
Sì, lo so che magari
vi spiazza questa definizione;
ma se voi pensate alla vostra esperienza,
noi tutti nasciamo nell'economia del dono.
Spero per voi che nessuno di voi
abbia dovuto pagare
per le cure parentali
che mamma e papà gli hanno fornito,
altrimenti veramente mi dispiace per voi
e sono lieto per il vostro analista,
che sicuramente avrà da lavorare con voi.
Ma questa economia del dono
non si allarga solo alla famiglia,
agli amici, ai vicini,
diciamo così tra virgolette
"a tutta la tribù".
È un'economia che però non scala,
perché prima o poi incontriamo
persone che non conosciamo
e per questo non ci fidiamo di loro;
o a volte, talvolta,
non ci fidiamo di loro
perché le conosciamo,
ma è un po' lo stesso.
E allora noi,
che però siamo intrinsecamente
animali socievoli,
siamo antropologicamente sociali,
vogliamo cooperare anche con coloro
di cui non ci fidiamo.
E allora, prima abbiamo
inventato il baratto:
io dò le mie uova a lei,
ma sarà il caso che io
debba volere il suo latte oggi.
Oppure, per disintermediare
nel tempo e nello spazio il baratto,
inventiamo la moneta:
un bene sintetico per cooperare
con coloro di cui non ci fidiamo.
Non so voi, ma io auspico
un momento di commozione intellettuale,
perché a me questa osservazione
sembra di una portata gigantesca:
la moneta è lo strumento per cooperare
con i nostri simili di cui non ci fidiamo.
E allora, è evidente che oggi,
in un'economia che per la prima volta
è un'economia dell'informazione,
digitale e globale,
viene la necessità
di una moneta sovranazionale,
di una moneta digitale.
Ma di una moneta
non controllata da Stati,
di una moneta globale,
di una moneta di Internet.
Il problema è che nel tentare di fare
una moneta di Internet
ci sono difficoltà gigantesche.
La difficoltà più grossa è il cosiddetto
"problema della doppia spesa".
Tutte le volte che noi abbiamo
un artefatto digitale
che rappresenta valore,
abbiamo sempre avuto bisogno
di un'autorità centrale,
che ne impedisca la duplicazione.
Sì, essendo digitale
è duplicabile, non è difficile:
pensate al saldo
del vostro conto corrente.
Se io bonificassi a lei
il saldo del mio conto corrente -
non si faccia illusioni, frattaglie,
quando poi tentassi
di bodificarlo anche al signore,
la mia banca,
che presiede all'aggiornamento
del suo registro contabile,
mi direbbe: "No Ferdinando,
non puoi farlo."
Come facciamo a creare
un asset digitale che abbia valore,
cioè non sia duplicabile, perché -
pensate ad esempio alla Gioconda.
Bellissima, senza dubbio.
Il suo prezzo di mercato è inestimabile.
Ma se fosse duplicabile arbitrariamente,
in un numero illimitato
di copie perfette,
resterebbe altrettanto bella,
ma il suo valore di mercato
crollerebbe a zero.
Bene, Bitcoin riesce proprio in questo,
ed è quindi limitato
a 21 milioni di Bitcoin.
Bitcoin, da un certo punto di vista,
è scarso come l'oro a livello fisico;
Bitcoin lo è a livello digitale.
Bitcoin è, o perlomeno vuole essere,
l'equivalente digitale dell'oro.
E qui io auspicherei
un secondo momento
di commozione intellettuale,
perché tutto sommato
sono abbastanza sicuro
che entrando in questo teatro
voi tutti siete entrati
convinti che qualsiasi cosa digitale
può essere duplicata.
Bitcoin vi smentisce
proprio su questo punto straordinario:
è un oro digitale,
peraltro con annesso,
intrinseco a Bitcoin medesimo,
il network transazionale,
incensurabile e sicuro,
con cui trasferire
a livello globale questo oro.
Lo so che siete scettici,
lo vedo dalle facce.
Allora facciamo un altro gioco:
immaginiamo che arrivi
un alieno, d'accordo?
Voi spiegate le monete tradizionali,
ed io spiego Bitcoin.
Io parto subito,
e comincio a dire all'alieno:
guarda che le loro monete
non hanno alcun valore intrinseco.
E voi, giustamente,
un po' piccati ribattete:
sì, ma Ferdinando, anche il tuo Bitcoin
non ha alcun valore intrinseco!
Ed io: ma come, vi ho appena spiegato
la scarsità in ambito digitale!
Ma avete gioco facile:
Sì però vuoi mettere
il contratto sociale,
secoli su questa storia
della moneta, il corso legale -
Bene, uno pari,
palla al centro, ripartiamo.
Io però a questo punto
incomincio a prendervi in giro,
dicendovi che il contante
che vi portate in giro
sono foglietti colorati.
Sì, va bene, carta speciale,
inchiostro speciale:
ma signori, sono le banconote
del Monopoli, né più né meno.
Invece, il mio contante
è matematica e crittografia.
Non solo, ma poi
faccio notare a questo alieno
che mentre io sono gentile,
il mio Bitcoin a voi
non lo forzo in alcun modo,
eh, voi siete abbastanza coercitivi.
Il vostro euro, io,
non posso fare a meno di usarlo.
Il corso legale dice
che se un mio debitore vuole saldare
il suo debito con me in euro,
io non posso rifiutarlo.
Lascio a voi ricavare
quale sia l'impressione
che l'alieno si farà di questa cosa.
Ah, ma dimenticavo: forse
bisognerebbe dire all'alieno, anche,
che abbiamo un signore a Francoforte -
uno serissimo per carità,
il più serio fra di noi,
che di quei foglietti di carta colorata
può stamparne quanti ne vuole,
quando vuole, darli a chi vuole,
non è stato eletto
e non dovrà rispondere a nessuno
di come interpreta il suo mandato.
Io invece ho già spiegato all'alieno
che la politica monetaria di Bitcoin
è perfettamente deterministica,
non influenzabile da nessuno.
Mi direte:
Sì, ma sto Bitcoin non lo usa nessuno.
Non si vedono transazioni in Bitcoin.
Eh, ci credo: chi ha comprato, nel 2010,
due pizze, pagandole 10.000 Bitcoin,
cioè al corso attuale
40 milioni di dollari -
be', speriamo che quelle pizze
fossero almeno molto, ma molto buone,
perché io non sarei riuscito
a digerirle in qualche modo.
Bitcoin è un bene rifugio,
quindi si tesaurizza,
e allora è più opportuno confrontarlo
non con la moneta, ma con l'oro fisico.
L'oro è stato accettato
da tutte le civilizzazioni
come prima forma di moneta,
senza alcuna pianificazione centralizzata.
Per secoli è stata la forma di moneta
di maggior successo,
ha innescato lo sviluppo
di tutti i sistemi monetari
che conosciamo,
è stato superato da forme
di moneta più sofisticata,
senza per questo diventare obsoleto.
Bene, quello che è successo
nei secoli all'oro fisico
sta succedendo in questi dieci anni,
e probabilmente nei prossimi decenni,
a Bitcoin.
Di Bitcoin spaventa moltissimo
questa volatilità: sale e scende.
Guardate che non c'è molto da spaventarsi.
Per carità, tutte le volte
che si parla di Bitcoin
fate bene ad allacciare
le cinture di sicurezza,
i percorsi sono sempre molto accidentati;
ma questa volatilità è fisiologica.
Quando domanda e offerta sul mercato
tentano di mettere a fuoco
il valore di un bene,
se questo bene è controverso,
come l'oro digitale,
il processo sarà altrettanto controverso.
Lo abbiamo visto accadere, nella storia,
anche per il commercio elettronico:
andate a guardare la storia
della quotazione di Amazon,
com'è volatile.
Di Bitcoin quello che spaventa, però,
è il cosiddetto drowdown,
cioè il fatto che da massimo a minimo
è stato in grado di perdere
ben oltre il 93 per cento del suo valore.
Quindi il messaggio da portare a casa
è che, se mai voleste
investire in Bitcoin,
vi prego, fatelo con una piccola
percentuale dei vostri risparmi,
con la quantità dei vostri risparmi
di cui potete, ragionevolmente,
sostenere la perdita integrale.
Ma la buona notizia
è che Bitcoin non ha correlazione
con le altre asset class di investimento,
con le altre opportunità di investimento:
non si muove assieme a loro,
diversifica i rischi;
quindi, introdotto
in un portafoglio d'investimento,
sembrerà paradossale,
ma abbatte i rischi di quel portafoglio
a parità di rendimento atteso,
o, a parità di rischio,
aumenta grandemente il rendimento atteso.
È quindi ragionevole fare
un piccolo investimento in Bitcoin,
e questo ci dà uno spunto
per qualche valutazione di massima.
Immaginiamo che il 2 percento
dei patrimoni gestiti -
badate, non parlo del 2 per cento
della ricchezza globale mondiale,
ma il 2 per cento dei patrimoni
gestiti professionalmente -
investano nei prossimi anni in Bitcoin.
Be', se facciamo due conti,
un bitcoin deve andare a valere
100 mila dollari.
Se Bitcoin invece è,
o dimostrasse di essere, oro digitale -
e dico se perché, ricordiamoci,
è un esperimento ardito,
e potrebbe fallire,
ma è un esperimento culturalmente
e tecnologicamente sostanziato -
ripeto, se fosse oro digitale,
be', signori, è meglio dell'oro fisico:
leggerissimo,
trasferibile istantaneamente,
con costi transazionali bassissimi,
senza problemi logistici,
in maniera incensurabile e inarrestabile.
E allora, se Bitcoin
andasse a capitalizzare
quanto capitalizza oggi l'oro al mondo,
un bitcoin dovrebbe
valere 400.000 dollari.
100.000 dollari, 400 mila dollari -
signori, io non sono qui
a vendere Bitcoin.
Io sto soltanto dicendo
che se Bitcoin è oro digitale,
allora oggi è grandemente sottovalutato.
Ma qualcuno mi obietta:
no, ma ho letto che non è il Bitcoin,
è la blockchain, la tecnologia
sottostante Bitcoin,
a essere fondamentale.
Io amo, da questo punto di vista,
parafrasare Confucio,
il quale diceva:
"Quando un uomo saggio indica la luna,
gli stolti guardano il dito".
La luna è Bitcoin,
e il dito la blockchain.
Perché non può sfuggirvi
la rilevanza del fenomeno Bitcoin.
Se avete un minimo di consapevolezza
di quale sia stato
il ruolo dell'oro fisico
nella storia della civilizzazione,
della finanza e della moneta,
l'emergere dell'equivalente
digitale dell'oro
nella civilizzazione digitale
e nel futuro della finanza e della moneta
sarà dirompente.
E allora, io concluderei
con una osservazione:
25-27 anni fa, io che usavo l'email
e in generale navigavo sul web,
non avrei mai potuto immaginare
che sul protocollo TCP/IP,
cioè sulla tecnologia
sottostante web ed e-mail,
avremmo in futuro
organizzato i nostri weekend
in dei club digitali - Facebook,
piuttosto che comprato libri e dischi
in formato liquido sui negozi online,
o ancora che avremmo fatto domande
in lingua naturale
ad un computer, a un assistente digitale,
aspettandoci delle risposte sensate.
Ecco io non so dirvi, tra 20 anni,
sul TCP/IP del valore, che cosa avremo,
quali applicazioni incredibili
ci potranno essere:
questa è proprio l'avventura
che aspetta tutti noi oltre l'orizzonte.
Grazie.
(Applausi)